mais à cette époque là j'étais sur un
petit nuage j'étais très très protégé
j'étais très bien vous étiez notre idole
je vous le dis tout de suite
mais dis bienvenue sur le plateau de
tout mon appareil alors vous êtes né le
26 mai 1956 à Choisy-le-Roi sous le nom
de Mehdi el mazouari El Glaoui en fait
votre père SIM Brahim El Glaoui était le
fils du pacha de Marrakech et pendant la
période du protectorat français en fait
le pacha de Marrakech avait une certaine
autonomie il s'est retrouvé
effectivement à avoir la charge de toute
une région assez vaste qui comprenait le
sud du Maroc le pays berbère la montagne
etc et donc comme il était très à
l'époque pour les Français et amis des
Français
le pouvoir local français Lyautey
notamment c'est beaucoup appuyé sur lui
et sur ces troupes pour pacifier entre
guillemets le sud du Maroc voilà alors
en 1956 au moment de l'indépendance du
Maroc Mohamed 5 rentre de son exil à
Madagascar et à ce moment-là c'est votre
père qui part en exil en France voilà
voilà bon la famille globalement est
plus ou moins mon père était très engagé
auprès de mon grand-père et donc
effectivement il a été condamné à l'exil
pendant 15 ans voilà alors votre mère
c'est Cécile Aubry alors Cécile Aubry
c'est une ravissante comédienne aux yeux
verts bronze et à la mouboudeuse
vraiment magnifique et Henri Georges
Clouzot avait fait des une star dans un
film qui s'appelait Manon absolument
maintenant obtient le Lion d'Or la
mostrade Venise en 1949 donc c'est dire
la popularité de votre mère à l'époque
alors elle signe alors un contrat avec
la twenty Century Fox pour un film qui
s'appelle la rose noire d'Henri Hathaway
avec Orson Welles et tion power c'est
quand même pas mal et c'est pendant le
tournage de La Rose Noire donc en 1950
dans les dunes de l'Atlas marocain
qu'elle rencontre votre père donc le
fils aîné du pacha de Marrakech il vient
visiter le plateau en fait et il était
caïd de Marrakech et donc elle a
liberté le tournage se placer là donc il
avait la responsabilité du tournage que
tout se passe bien etc et ça a pas
manqué je crois qu'il est tombé amoureux
de de la comédienne principale voilà
alors elle épouse son prince charmant
dans le plus grand secret et pendant 6
ans personne ne va se douter qu'ils sont
mariés femme en fait c'est pas cher
surtout qui était pas au courant et qui
qui a priori n'était pas tout à fait
d'accord pour cette union ça s'est
inventé assez vite et je pense que le
pacha fait semblant de pas savoir
d'accord en votre mère à l'époque
s'installe dans la propriété du Moulin
Bleu vers Dourdan c'est ça voilà alors
pendant sa grossesse elle éprouve le
besoin de faire quelque chose elle
commence à dessiner alors au départ pour
elle-même pour le plaisir quoi et
ensuite très rapidement elle se met à
faire des livres pour enfants voilà
c'est à dire qu'en fait elle a elle a
rencontré des un éditeur qui s'appelle
Émile Paul à l'époque qui qui trouvait
ses dessins formidables et lui ont
proposé de de dialoguer tout ça d'en
faire une histoire et ça a bien marché
connaissez en 1956 donc votre mère
dites-vous à l'époque il a un teint de
petits pains sortant du four c'est
génial ça vous me la prenez mais trois
ans plus tard vos parents décident de
divorcer d'un commun accord ouais je
pense que mon père a mal vécu son exil
et puis bah voilà c'est la vie de couple
moderne malheureusement ça arrive assez
régulièrement et là votre mère lance un
défi à desmeures montant des millénaires
elle veut garder l'enfant alors ce qui
est contraire à la loi coranique en fait
parce que l'enfant appartient au père il
reste avec le père et elle décide de
s'opposer à ça elle ne veut pas que vous
soyez arraché au Moulin Bleu pour être
élevé à la marocaine oui enfin très très
honnêtement ça s'est passé calmement je
tiens mon père a fait des études à
l'école des roches etc donc bref il
était civilisé et il comprenait très
bien que maman elle me gardait et puis
voilà il y a c'était une incommode à
corps
j'ai pas vu beaucoup mon papa c'est vrai
mais mais c'était comme ça quoi enfin je
veux dire il y avait pas de conflit de
voilà c'était pas
une tu verras ton fils autant que tu le
voudras et autant que lui le voudra mais
je le garde et donc vous êtes resté avec
votre maman au Moulin Bleu et votre
grand-mère alors entre-temps votre mère
c'est inventé une autre vie elle écrit
elle réalise et vous jouez alors elle
commence toute seule avec une petite
caméra c'est presque du cinéma amateur
les acteurs c'était les enfants du
village quoi voilà
et puis ça prend de l'ampleur jusqu'au
moment où Gaumont s'y intéresse alors
vous avez quatre ans lorsque vous jouez
pour la première fois Pascal dans le
premier opus de la série des Polly voilà
alors police un poney c'est un poney
magnifique avec une crinière blonde
sublime et
donc voilà moi pour moi c'était un
souvenir extraordinaire quoi c'était des
vacances parce que à 4 ans je
rencontrais des copains il y avait un
cirque il y avait des animaux c'était le
rêve et vous aviez tu connais en fait
qui s'appelait Barbara qui a inspiré
poli mais vous savez tout vous êtes très
bien aussi c'est vrai
alors ensuite vient la série Belle et
Sébastien alors là c'est un véritable
triomphe vous devenez un enfant star
enfin à l'époque on disait un enfant
vedette vous êtes extrêmement célèbre
alors quels ont été les réactions
d'abord votre réaction comment vous vous
avez vécu ça moi j'étais pas très
conscient de ce qui se passait enfin je
veux dire quand on tourne ce genre de
choses à l'âge que j'avais bon d'abord
c'était une autre époque les médias
n'étaient pas aussi développés
qu'aujourd'hui tout le monde n'avait pas
envie de devenir célèbre en faisant la
Star Academy voilà voilà et moi surtout
pas c'était pas mon but du tout non je
me rendais pas compte de l'impact que ça
aurait après d'ailleurs maman non plus
je pense pas qu'elle pensait que ça
marcherait autant et que ça aurait un
tel retentissement mais donc moi c'est
pareil je m'amusais beaucoup sur les
tournages je rencontrais des techniciens
je m'intéressais à tout j'étais pas
forcément très discipliné pareil et
voilà non c'était c'était une éclate
totale pour moi voilà bon votre mère
j'imagine qu'elle était très heureuse de
tout ça oui mais elle était elle aussi
un petit peu dépassée par par le par le
succès et par parce qu'il s'est passé
par la Suisse quoi
c'était un peu moins moins sympa quoi et
votre père il a réagi comment
soit qui était fier moi on en a jamais
parlé j'ai pas eu l'occasion
malheureusement d'en parler avec lui je
pense qu'il était fier de ce qui se
passait parce qu'il se tenait au courant
il se renseignait j'ai retrouvé des
courriers ou justement il se pose la
question est-ce que c'est bien pour pour
l'enfant etc donc il était déjà un petit
peu inquiet mais il était en même temps
fier de ce qui se passait je crois alors
les médias à l'époque c'était pas comme
maintenant vous devez faire des des
couvertures de magazines enfin c'était
beaucoup plus calme finalement vous
vivez une enfance simple et chanceuse
vous dites très bien que vous êtes au
Moulin Bleu vous allez prendre des cours
de judo à Dourdan et des cours
d'équitation à Saint-Cyr donc tout va
bien oui oui c'était une vie d'enfant
rêvée
mais alors il y a qu'un truc dans vos
gardez pas un très bon souvenir c'est
l'école des Frères des Écoles
chrétiennes là oui parce que bon d'abord
j'étais ado et puis ça me convenait pas
quoi il y a des gens pour qui ça peut
apporter beaucoup
ça m'a apporté une certaine rigueur on
va dire mais c'est tout c'est le reste
je regarde pas un super bon
souvenirs
non pas du tout enfin c'était non non
c'était dérisoire et puis c'était pas le
but enfin je veux dire dans mon cas de
toute façon c'est de l'argent que je
n'aurais touché qu'à 18h donc entre 6
ans et 18 ans d'imaginais bien que ça
fait ça fait pas grand chose et puis non
c'était pas du tout bien payé c'était il
y avait pas d'agents enfin je veux dire
c'est pas organisé comme aujourd'hui et
alors à l'école vu être la petite star
dans vous allez avoir toutes les filles
alors folle de vous non non j'avais une
sorte de complexe au contraire je
voulais essayer d'être le plus discret
et le plus normal possible c'est à la
mode et j'avais réussi en fait est-ce
que les gamins au bout d'un moment quand
vous avez une attitude normale justement
ils oublient totalement qui vous êtes et
c'est presque plus avec les profs que
j'ai des petits problèmes parce que dès
qu'on travaille moins bien
voilà on s'est dit ça y est lui il a la
grosse tête non c'est pas le cas c'était
simplement j'étais pas hyper assidu à
l'école j'étais pas un très bon élève la
vérité alors quel était le meilleur
moment de cette époque c'est vrai que
les tournages pour moi étaient
fantastiques parce que je sortais d'un
milieu scolaire enfin j'étais à l'école
comme tout le monde et puis l'été enfin
tous les deux étaient en plus c'était
pas intense c'était tous les deux ans
l'été je tournais je crois que c'est ça
les meilleurs moments avec le chien et
tout ça et puis vous avez eu la chance
de tourner avec Charles Vanel dans
Sébastien et la Marie Morgan ce qui est
incroyable c'est que Charles Vanel il
avait commencé bébé aussi il faisait
bébé donc pour moi il était déjà vieux
mais oui c'est fou alors qu'il a tourné
de l'âge de 3 ans à l'âge de 4 ans c'est
un peu comme vous finalement et si je
pouvais avoir sa longévité je serais
très fier quel était le pire moment de
toute cette j'étais très protégé par ma
maman peut-être trop mais ce qui fait
que j'ai pas senti du tout la pression
ou la jalousie etc par la suite après
quand je me suis un petit peu émancipé à
partir de 15 ans c'était un peu plus
difficile mais à cette époque là j'étais
sur un petit nuage j'étais très très
protégé j'étais très bien vous étiez
notre idole je vous le dis tout de suite
alors ensuite fait quelques films comme
acteur ouais et puis vous passez à la
réalisation oui j'apprends mon métier
quoi parce que j'ai essayé de tenter
l'idée que je me suis fait jeter comme
un malpropre et puis j'étais assistant
Réal de plein de gens dont notamment
Yves Robert et puis j'ai fait des
courts-métrages voilà et puis finalement
votre carrière d'acteur et c'est un peu
ralenti quoi vous dites quand ça
s'arrête ça s'arrête quoi oui bon j'ai
peut-être un peu cherché j'ai pas
l'habitude de mettre ça sur le dos des
autres je pense que je suis je suis en
grande partie responsable c'est à dire
qu'à un moment j'ai cru que ça allait
continuer et en fait c'est un métier où
il faut sans arrêt faire du relationnel
travailler à prendre son métier parce
que ça s'apprend aussi mais tu es de
comédien alors j'avais pas de bagages je
tournais à l'instant et puis je me suis
dit ça va continuer comme ça puis en
fait non c'est plus laborieux plus
difficile j'ai quand même réussi à
travailler soit au théâtre soit comme
acteur relativement régulièrement avec
des longs trous mais je pense que tous
les acteurs ont connu ça on a des
périodes de
long de longues inactivité
malheureusement alors aujourd'hui est-ce
que vous êtes nostalgique de l'époque
Belle et Sébastien pas du tout je suis
ravi d'avoir vécu ça surtout à cette
époque là ça aurait pas aimé le vivre
aujourd'hui le jour où vous allez mourir
qu'elle voulait qu'on écrive sur votre
temps de midi ce serait Sébastien s'est
fait la belle oh c'est bien ah c'est
vachement bien merci c'est très heureux
de rallumer la lumière sur vos mails
merci à vous et pour être sûr de ne rien
rater de Inna larditude abonnez-vous et
mettez un pouce bleu